Whether it's an X-Men film, the next chapter
in the MCU, or an entry in the DC Extended
Universe, superhero movies are filled with
some truly incredible moments.
These films are about super-poweredbeings
who fight crime, serve justice, and provide
humanity with hope.
As a result, they've given us all kinds of
epic moments and stunning visuals that'll
make you want to slam that pause button.
It all started in 2008, when Tony Stark announced:
"I am Iron Man."
After that, we were introduced to a green
rage monster, a star-spangled soldier, the
god of thunder, and two deadly assassins.
But we hadn't seen them all together yet,
until The Avengers came along.
Directed by Joss Whedon, this 2012 mega-hit
assembled Earth's mightiest heroes for the
very first time.
They bickered, they bantered, they battled
aliens, and every scene built towards possibly
the greatest hero shot in cinematic history.
In the final act of the film, Loki and his
Chitauri army are attacking New York City.
Five of the six Avengers are doing their best
to hold back the aliens, but then there's
a toothy space whale joins the fray.
Fortunately, that's when a bedraggled Bruce
Banner shows up.
He gets mad, Hulk smashes the Leviathan, and
the angry Chitauri surround the Avengers,
letting loose with a terrifying war cry.
But these heroes aren't afraid.
Instead, they all stand back-to-back, preparing
for war, as the camera circles around them
and you'll need to press pause so you can
fully revel in such an awesome moment.
Black Panther introduced the world to Killmonger,
possibly the greatest villain to wreak havoc
in the MCU.
Played by Michael B. Jordan, he's a black
ops soldier who wants the Wakandan throne,
but before he can rule, he must defeat King
T'Challa.
Even though it's an incredibly advanced nation,
Wakanda still practices ritual combat.
If you beat the king, you get the crown, and
Killmonger has been training his entire life
for this.
As his name implies, he's been racking up
an impressive body count, and every time he
takes a life, he marks his body with a scar.
At first, we only see a few bumps on his forearm,
but when it comes time to fight T'Challa,
he pops that shirt off and reveals he's absolutely
covered in little dots.
According to Jordan, there were over 2000
of those bumps, which adds up to a lot of
corpses.
It's a terrific and terrifying reveal, showing
that Killmonger is going to be the toughest
challenge that T'Challa has ever faced.
On top of that, seeing Killmonger in all his
glory prompted quite a bit of thirst from
Michael B. Jordan fans.
"Every time I think about Michael B. Jordan
my uterus bursts into flames."
"Oh, man!"
The airport battle in Captain America: Civil
War might be the greatest comic book movie
moment of all time.
All these heroes are coming together for an
epic showdown.
Nobody wants to kill anyone, and they're mostly
friends, so they're going to exchange as many
quips as kicks.
Still, that doesn't stop them from shooting
arrows, tossing cars, and blowing things up.
As a result, you've got a fun-filled action
scene filled with pause-worthy moments that
need some extra appreciation.
For example, there's the first appearance
of the MCU's new Spider-Man, the moment that
Giant-Man snags War Machine out of the air,
and any time that Black Panther is going to
town.
But the scene that deserves the most attention
comes when both groups finally square off.
When it becomes clear that Cap's team isn't
backing down, the two groups rush at each
other for a superhero extravaganza.
As the Avengers battle each other in this
melee of epic proportions, the pause button
will come in handy if you want to see who
fights whom, how they're using their powers,
and who's the toughest hero in this crazy
civil war.
When you're playing the Joker, you've got
to make a big entrance.
And on that score, it's hard to compete with
Heath Ledger's strange and scary intro in
The Dark Knight.
In one of the best opening scenes of all time,
a gang of robbers, all wearing clown masks,
hit one of the biggest banks in Gotham.
But as they deactivate the alarm system and
crack the safe, we hear them talking about
their murderous and mysterious employer: the
Joker.
The clown thieves whisper about how the Joker
wears warpaint and how he's totally crazy.
He's also quite dangerous, as he's ordered
the robbers to pick each other off, one by
one.
Eventually, there's only one clown left, and
he's about to make his big getaway, when he
hears somebody screaming after him.
It's the bank manager, and he's none too impressed
with these mask-wearing thugs.
And that's when we get the money shot.
The clown gets in the bank manager's face
and pulls off his mask to reveal that, yes
indeed, he is the Joker.
He's got greasy hair, darkened eyes, and big
scars.
It's then that you'll want to pause the film
so you can admire that impeccably choreographed
heist, and also so that you can calm down
after staring straight into the eyes of chaos.
Tony Stark has always been the most complicated
Avenger, but when he first appeared in 2008's
Iron Man, he was a straight-up jerk.
He was completely self-centered and amoral,
and he made his living as a "merchant of death."
He sold weapons of mass destruction, and until
he was captured by terrorists, he didn't care
where his missiles ended up.
Despite all this, his obnoxious attitude gave
us one of the most pause-worthy moments in
the MCU: when he proudly presents his Jericho
missiles.
Ever the showman, Tony gives a razzle-dazzle
speech to a group of Army officers as he fires
his weapon into an Afghani desert.
The missile opens mid-air and sends a dozen
tiny rockets tumbling down into the mountains
below.
As they ignite some massive explosions, Tony
spreads his arms like a circus ringmaster,
and it's here that you'll want to press pause.
The smoke is billowing in the background,
the shock wave is heading straight for the
camera, and Tony's hubris is on full display.
Director Christopher Nolan has a knack for
creating truly staggering visuals.
And one of the most breathtaking is the burning
Bat Symbol in The Dark Knight Rises.
This 2012 flick finds Gotham City in a world
of trouble.
The villainous Bane has taken over, and he's
holding everybody hostage with a neutron bomb.
He's cut off all escape routes, trapped the
police in the sewer system, and worse still,
he recently broke Batman's back and tossed
him into an underground prison.
Things are looking grim for the citizens of
Gotham, especially Commissioner Gordon, who's
about to get iced, and that's when Batman
shows up to save the day.
You can't keep a good bat down, and after
Batman fixes his back and escapes the pit,
he rescues Gordon from his incredibly cold
fate.
But the rest of the city needs to know help
is on the way, so the two crimefighters light
a giant flaming Bat Symbol atop a nearby bridge.
The burning logo gives everyone hope, and
it's such a powerful shot that it's worth
pausing the film to admire the flames.
Hugh Jackman joined the X-Men in 2000, and
he proceeded to play the cigar-chomping Wolverine
for over 16 years.
In fact, he holds the Guinness world record
for "longest career as a live-action Marvel
superhero," along with his X-Men co-star Patrick
Stewart.
So when it came time for Jackman to say goodbye
in Logan, it broke a lot of Marvel fans' hearts.
Fortunately, the 2017 film gave the character
a proper goodbye.
He went out fighting, protecting children
from an evil band of scientists and soldiers,
and he was sent off with one of cinema's most
emotional eulogies.
With tears welling in her eyes, the young
Laura stands over Logan's grave and delivers
a monologue from the classic western film
Shane.
"Tell her everything's all right.
There are no more guns in the valley."
After the speech, she reaches over to Logan's
grave marker and flips it on its side, turning
a cross into an "X."
You'll want to hit the pause button here because
the tears will be flowing, and you'll also
want to marvel at that final shot of the grave,
a tender farewell to the most famous of the
X-Men.
Ever since the credits of the first Avengers
film, Marvel fans knew Thanos was coming.
The Mad Titan finally made his move in Avengers:
Infinity War, rounding up all the Infinity
Stones and halving the population of the universe
with a single snap.
But before that heartbreaking moment, the
Avengers did their best to stop the purple
warlord, and none were quite as effective
as Dr. Strange.
The surgeon-turned-sorcerer was a key player
in Infinity War, protecting the Time Stone
from the Black Order and battling Thanos himself
on Titan.
And it's on this desolate planet that Strange's
powers are on full display.
He opens portals for Spider-Man to jump through,
he helps Star-Lord run through the air, and
his cloak even gets in on the action.
In fact, the best moment of the Titan fight
is when Strange and Thanos go mano-a-mano.
The most pause-worthy image comes when Strange
sprouts multiple arms to perform the Images
of Ikonn.
You'll want to hit pause again when there
are about 100 Dr. Strange's attacking Thanos
with 100 Eldritch Whips.
Basically, any time Strange and Thanos are
throwing down, you'll want to pause the movie
and admire the magic.
As played by Gal Gadot, Wonder Woman, a.k.a.
Diana Prince, was both kind and courageous,
gentle and deadly.
She was a compassionate god-killer, and we
got to see both sides on display during one
of the greatest action scenes in superhero
history: the battle of No Man's Land.
During a mission to stop an evil German general,
Diana learns that a village full of innocents
has been captured by enemy troops.
Putting her mission on hold, she decides to
rescue the helpless villagers by walking across
the most dangerous stretch of ground on the
Western Front.
With the help of her bulletproof bracelets,
she storms across No Man's Land, blocking
shots and deflecting bombs like it's an afternoon
stroll through the park.
As Diana walks through explosions and streaks
of flame, you'll need to press the pause button
multiple times to fully absorb her awesomeness.
There's the scene when she steps onto the
battlefield in her full Wonder Woman regalia.
There's the moment when she blocks the first
bullet, and then there's the scene when she
pulls out that shield and stops a barrage
of machine gun blasts.
It's maybe the most inspirational scene in
any DC movie, and any time you press pause,
you can't help but stare in wonder.
In the 2018 animated film Spider-Man: Into
the Spider-Verse, there's no scene more visually
impressive than the moment Miles Morales finally
takes a leap of faith.
Throughout the film, this teenager has been
struggling with way more than any kid should
ever have to deal with.
He's suddenly gotten super powers, but he
doesn't know how to use them, and he's scared
he might never live up to his potential.
On top of all that, there are supervillains
trying to kill him, which never makes things
easier.
Grappling with his dual identities, Miles
finally owns his Spider-persona, adapting
his suit to fit his own background and personality,
before literally taking a leap off an enormous
skyscraper.
As Miles free-falls through the air, he passes
through a gorgeous cityscape lit with neon
blues, dark purples, and smooth pinks.
He's directly at the center of the frame,
surrounded by giant, hulking buildings.
The world seems so big, Miles seems so small,
and he's falling so fast.
But when he blasts those web shooters and
begins swinging through the city, he is Spider-Man.
He's done more than enough to earn the cover
to his own comic, and this scene has done
more than enough to earn a few admiring pauses.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.